This week was terrible.
I hated it, and I'm
never doing this again.
I'm Abby. I love coffee,
and I am giving it up for a week
because Business Insider's making me.
I drink coffee every day,
multiple times a day,
many different types: cold, hot.
And I'm gonna give it up, I guess.
I have no idea how many
cups of coffee I drink.
Just like a constant
state of refilling my mug.
At home, it's harder because
I have to make it myself
and I'm lazy, so I'll usually
just have one French press
'cause that's as much as I can deal with.
I think the max is like
several cold brews.
I can drink it cold much
faster, which is very dangerous
'cause I drink a lotta coffee,
and then I talk twice as
fast and twice as much,
and so I think I end up
lowering productivity of my team overall.
My biggest challenges are
gonna be not drinking coffee.
I think it's gonna be, like,
getting into the swing of things
in the morning is gonna be tough.
So tomorrow will be my
first day without coffee.
I am not excited for it, pretty sad,
but I'm going to be too
tired to complain about it.
Today was my first day without coffee.
Honestly, I forgot.
I didn't drink coffee
because I am very sick.
The hardest part about
not having coffee today
was around 3 p.m. when I realized
I still had to keep working.
But as the week goes on,
and I get over this illness,
and I get angrier
and angrier about not getting coffee,
I think it's gonna get worse.
It is day three, no coffee.
I'm not sick anymore, and I'm
feeling the caffeine loss.
Right after lunch is when I will usually
go and get my second or
third coffee of the day.
And I couldn't do that today,
so I almost fell asleep at my desk.
I just want it back.
Right around 2 or 3 p.m. is
when I start to lose all focus.
I feel significantly more
tired today in the afternoon.
Here's when I want coffee
in general during the day.
I want it right when I get to work.
That's part of my routine:
desk-kitchen-desk.
And then I want it immediately after lunch
'cause I eat too much and I
make myself tired that way,
so I've gotta combat it
with another cup of coffee.
The first one is the easiest to skip
because there's more to do
at the beginning of the day,
and so I get distracted.
But the post-lunch cups are a necessity.
Everybody around me is drinking coffee.
The desk to my right has a coffee.
She's got a standing desk,
and I'm not standing,
so the coffee is right at my
eye level, which is torture.
I can smell it. I can see it.
For whatever reason, people
got monster-size coffees today.
I feel like it was to torture me.
So I'm not looking forward to
the next few days without coffee.
I'm really looking forward to being done.
The plan was to get up around 9
and start packing my apartment.
It's now 11:30.
I can't get over this tired hump
without a cup of coffee.
OK, so this week was different
than I thought it would be.
It wasn't really like
things got really hard
and then it was fine. Some
days were harder than others.
The days that I was home were hardest
because I didn't have anything to focus on
other than wanting coffee,
and then the occasional afternoon at work,
mostly because it disrupted my routine.
I was more tired at times,
but I think the biggest hurdle to get over
was just not having that
as a part of my day.
So I would get to work in the morning,
not get my cup of coffee,
and then immediately just be grumpy.
And then, finishing the
day was also difficult
because I'm used to having
that second pick-me-up.
I was like, "I don't really
wanna do this, but I have to."
And usually, with my cup of coffee,
I'm like, "All right, it's time to work."
So I think it was more an attitude change
than a productivity change.
I definitely had less headaches this week,
almost none, probably 'cause
I was drinking more water
and less caffeine.
That being said, I still want the coffee.
People kept hiding their coffee from me,
so I at least know that I made
other people uncomfortable
throughout this while I was uncomfortable.
I don't wanna cut coffee out.
Coffee and I, we're like this,
and I'm not willing to lose
that relationship quite yet.
Thank you.
It's perfect.
This is the best kind of ice too.